yo guys what's up this prestige here and
today I got a mod spotlight for you guys
mod spotlight macho case whatever you
want to call it it's a pretty awesome
mod if I do say so myself you got
ravines you got village if I was gonna
say villages but village since only one
you got epic caverns young above-ground
dungeon you got diamonds everyone wants
diamonds so we're gonna hop right into
the sea so I'm going to go to single
player and I'm gonna go to my new world
I'll show you guys the sea don't worry
so that's just part of them out i have
on another mod that yeah did we forget
about the chat forget about chat but if
we go into if we do / seed then we'll
get our c- 7535 for 8 930 and all
that'll be in the description for you
guys now so you see you spawn on a
little it's a Miss like that vocabulary
of a force that stretches out to more
forest it's got some still force against
next with like very nice like but if you
turn your back where you spawn you see
this and boom cavern plus ravine that is
a pretty cool ravine actually haven't
checked this out to see if there are any
uh if there any of those good old do
your moans in here but I let's do a
quick check ya go why don't second boom
yeah normal which if you get normal so
yeah so this mod is definitely the mod
not a mod spotlight sassy totally I say
oh if I stood Model T and I apologize
this is a seed so we got some margarine
right there we got some coals sound
looking like we're gonna hit anything a
mad demons got some more margarine
margins always nice I don't think weird
even at it oh my double ravine double
ravine bro there's a double ravine this
this but even know this existed oh my
gosh does this seed is just so good oh
my gosh so we got a double ravine to
start it out double ravine
I'm not gonna waste guys here there
might be some diamonds in here come
check it out a lot of water but I won't
waste your time with that so let's go
back up since I want to show you what I
what I have plan to show you some that's
a pretty cool as well so we got the got
the double ravine here so that's legit
so you head over here we see a village
now you notice some extra stuff in the
village it's not like this is a special
village that's just part of the mod
ahead so instantly you hit a village I
haven't checked to see if there's a
black ball there's a blacksmith shop so
let's go see if we can get any good from
the blacksmith shop do-do-do-do-do that
his furnaces are dry not cooking any of
the goods but we are oh I iron helmet
iron chestplate two sets of Iron Boots
and iron pickaxe that is some good finds
if I do say so myself and guess a few
farms you want some wheat seeds this is
a very hilly uh very hilly village and
is this lover oh yeah books too man this
is just all around good and got a church
Cena there's a priest so you can get
that good goods so oh this is just
beautiful village beautiful village ones
like let me hit that time set 0 x 0
alright since we want to be in full
daylight when we doing this so you see
you already have two ravines a village
with legit stuff legit our armors
murmurs legit armors got some ton of
weeks and seeds and stuff go over here
by this jungle and some lava let me turn
that music down a bit that musics
annoying we got some above-ground lava
if you want for everyone some lava got a
nice jungle biome and if you saw that
that's part either matsu I'm pretty sure
this part of them are maybe it's some
weird structure whoo but if we keep
going down here just follow the jungle
trail till you hit the raver follow the
river a little bit we should be hitting
one of my pre-placed beacons sometime
soon see you just follow the river up
here follow my path and also I found
this on the mod for nut muffin I keep
saying ma see forms well just the forms
I searched for some epic seeds it's okay
here we go stuff yeah just some epic
seeds you can find so credit that are
I'm all should have the link in the
description so we go ahead of this this
first beacon gotten all this is one
amazing cavern look at this is just
hollowed out beautiful for like a base
or any sort of structure gonna build
like this is just looked pretty up like
five different entrances to caverns tons
of iron mmm perfection we go over here
you saw this other one this is above
ground Arjun I haven't actually looked
at this so let's see what type dungeon
it is a skeleton smaller very good to
make an XP farm that is what you're
gonna want that is what you want now
we're going to go over here the chests
okay we got to music discs we've got a
name tag some string redstone settle so
I'd say the saddle name tag and the
music discs are where it's at now we got
another one and we got some iron a lot
more of the same music disc okay you can
have a ton of that music disc and just
some other it's so that's the most
amazing thing but I'll when I see a
spawner when I find a skeleton spawner
i'm always happy more for the smaller
than for the loot because you can make
an XP farm out of skeletons or or
zombies I guess spiders too but that's a
lot harder so let's do that now we're
getting it into what I know you guys
came for for the Diamonds now all right
you go over here you hit this it's going
to be a cord 650 negative 66 around
there around that area gonna hit at the
start of the forest near the sand with a
sand meets the force basically you're
gonna hit a big dip in the ground it
just oh my gosh look how many ores oh my
i iron iron iron coal coal iron oh this
this it's just so good so you follow
this dip down to the water down the
waterfall the waterfall is actually
really sick I actually think this is a
really interesting Oh more eye on them
gosh I think this is a really
interesting area like you see some of
these but this is bigger than most gonna
follow this to hit the gravel you can go
explore there for some more iron some
love a cold o.o your basic cavern needs
and you follow down oh what's that go
past the gravel and boom you hit your
first board diamond that is a trial
where I think yep that is a try or and
up what's another orb diamonds and is
that going to be all all
that is some legit diamonds legit doms
off is that more iron more I'd more I
and oh my gosh Ollie on so so far we
have 3 plus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so sorry 6 I
just counted these ones twice so that
six that's nine diamonds and you may
think okay that's it they can't be any
more than that but you'd be wrong oh oh
oh it's gonna be all this from there's
some water awesome when did this water
come down here I don't remember doing
that oh well but you guys saw it dear
moans there's gonna be some love here of
naturally so expect this to be lava and
have fun navigating around that but
we're gonna close this off ok close you
all so we can see at least two diamonds
three diamonds dang three diamonds so
that's going to be yet you see there's a
lava and i think i think it's it's yes
all diamonds are three that is 12
diamonds you can start right up back you
make a diamond helmet and a pic you can
make some tools just some legit stuff
you make a chestplate are so actually
there's one thing that i noticed I've I
have entered my inventory and you can
show you guys the stronghold that is
right next to spawn so I'm just gonna
fly myself over there yeah I remember I
remember I just mapped out where to go
but yeah it's over here it's over here
so one tier around this I remember I was
thinking though this is there's only
this cavern if there's someone else and
it's the stronghold so once you get here
you can start throwing your odds of
Enders and it's gonna be pretty close
now you're gonna see they're gonna be
going on I I think I made up let make it
bacon I'll know what is this I'll get
that something from my ma that's inform
odd okay but uh let's see what the girls
let's see where they go okay come on
where you going we're going we're going
okay keep going this way keep on this
way come on this way so we're gonna go
this way for a bit I'm gonna see y'all
another I pick this see just has tons
there it is let's see just as tons of
epic mini mini ravines but caverns SC
our coordinates uh 650 240
hit up you hit that you hit you can see
the eyes Avengers going straight down so
we're gonna tunnel our way down a bit
I'm creative as you guys hopefully know
by now so I can just smash them all be
careful when you're going down cuz you
don't want to break the end afraid but
yeah so oh that is that's bingo right
where you wanna be and then you can
explore this stronghold find all the
rest of the goodies that it entails as
strongholds normally do our guy so I say
that's it for the mod spotlight this mod
oh my god whom iron mod I'd not smart
seed alright guys so this seed let's go
through it it has a village right next
to spawn with tons of iron tons of books
and tons of wheat it has a double ravine
from your back that could have diamonds
it has an aboveground saw a skeleton
spawner not zombie it has 12 diamonds
easy to find it has a stronghold linux
to spawn and it it just has epic scenery
it is wow normal really doesn't get that
far I'm a normal Sun lag I don't like a
computer so man this this guy's this is
just looking beautiful so I hope you
guys enjoyed this if you did make sure
you leave a like great comment or
subscribe if this gets good feedback
i'll do more of these and yeah so dimes
galore my name's receive i'll see you
all later peace
guy
ha
I look at the boom